The pigeons in B.F. Skinner's box didn't just peck at a lever, they became fanatics.
Starved for certainty, they threw themselves against the glass, desperate for the next crumb, even when the food never came.
Skinner called it intermittent reinforcement. We call it addiction.
And now, we're the pigeons.
The lever is the for-you feed. The box is the screen.
The crumbs, whatever the algorithm decides to drop into our laps at random.
We don't even know what we're hungry for anymore. The machine does.
This is algorithm worship, the slow surrender of your mind to a recommendation engine.
You don't choose what you watch. You don't choose what you think.
The algorithm does. And it doesn't care about truth. It cares about you.
It starts with serendipity's death.
Remember the old days, when you stumbled upon a song on the radio or a book in a dusty corner of a shop, and it changed you?
That was chance. Now, chance is a crime.
Algorithms don't want you to discover anything unexpected.
They want you trapped in a filter, bubble a digital womb, where every thought, every image, every outrage is tailored to confirm what you already believe.
Personalization? No. Intellectual claustrophobia.
You're not being served. You're being optimized.
Here's how it works.
First, you stop searching.
You never type a single word into that bar.
You just click the first thing the algorithm shoves in front of you.
Let it decide.
Before long, you forget what you actually like.
The machine knows better than you do.
Then, you feed the outrage.
The angrier you get, the more it gives you.
Every like, every share,
every furious reply.
It's all data.
The algorithm doesn't want you to think.
It wants you reacting.
You're not questioning.
And if you're reacting, you're not questioning.
You're not growing.
You're just another data point in a never-ending loop of conflict.
Next, you purge the dissent.
If someone disagrees with you,
mute, block, delete.
Your feed becomes a mirror,
reflecting only your own voice polished,
amplified, safe.
No contradictions allowed.
No surprises.
Just the echo of your own certainty,
growing louder with every like.
Finally, you worship the metrics.
If the algorithm doesn't boost your post,
that's not a glitch.
That's failure.
Your worth isn't measured in ideas anymore.
It's measured in engagement,
in shares,
in time spent.
The numbers are your God.
And the algorithm?
It's the high priest,
whispering in your ear,
you're not enough.
But we can fix that.
And what do you get in the end?
An optimized consumer.
You're predictable.
You're engaged.
You're profitable.
You're a ghost in the machine
known better than you know yourself,
fed just enough to keep you pecking,
just enough to keep you there.
The algorithm doesn't want you to be happy.
It wants you to be present,
always present,
always clicking,
always waiting for the next drop of dopamine,
the next scrap of validation.
Doomscrolling for breakfast,
lunch,
dinner.
The algorithm sets your baseline
before you even wake up.
Addicted,
that's the default now.
The pigeons in Skinner's box
never learn to stop.
Neither will you.
Because the lever doesn't just give you food.
It gives you nothing at all.